you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on chess
calms tactics trainer and I'm going to
work my way through three puzzles and
just share my train of thought along the
way okay we are playing as black in this
first one you guys
coming in this direction
with a discovered check but light is
only a move away from queening width
check so a check here and then after a
king move picking up the brook won't cut
it
I don't think at least okay maybe we
could actually give me yeah we could we
could give me you know this is a
director mate okay so we have again
going after a piece isn't going to be
good enough so we have to go after the
king
rook here with cheque and we give a
check with the pawn if the King goes to
g2 the King goes to f1 we give a check
here
forcing then King to g2 have three check
yeah
okay so here's one line rook III King F
one rook e1 check King G to only move
three check with the rook on the back
rank the King now only has each to
Bishop g3 is then mate
okay let's consider one more variation
rookie tree instead of king f1 suppose
King g2 straightaway
imagine we take this opportunity to push
with f3 and okay from then the King has
a few options if he goes to f1 its mate
well pretty much if he goes to the back
rank we go here with check forcing king
h2 and then we go to g3 and the last
variation would be rookie three king G
to f3 king h2 okay from there we first
give a check with the bishop forcing the
king to the back and then rookie want to
be mate so the bishop in pawn in summary
will be able to control the second rank
squares this is kind of how I'm
visualizing it pawn on f3 Bishop on g3
controls the second rank squares and the
rook will be able to take care of the
first rank squares we have this
intersection Square on a1 both bishop
and rook so let's put it on it is right
to check check and mate
to go after the rook it's just not going
to be enough because this pawn is super
fast
okay try puzzle too
team white okay
I don't think we can give mate we only
have one attacking piece I don't think
that that will be enough the rook and
Knight are unprotected so how can we
maybe skewer the king and rook get to
the eighth-ranked somehow
or how can we give check and pick up the
night these are my thoughts at the
moment on if it's black to move there is
night f4 so we probably have to be
pretty Swift here very direct moves like
what made me think about that for a
second is could we get this pawn
involved with e6 no we can't
night at 4:00 so checking moves this is
our only checking move queen g4 okay oh
maybe we just attack the night from c4
or and okay if he goes to h7 we we go to
e4 whit's check and pick up the night
clean g4 King f8 however I think it's
enough to just play Queen C form
initially I thought Queen efore to put
pressure on the knight in Bishop but
that runs into Knight c3 I think it's
just clean G for Queen C for the knight
is kicked away from defending the bishop
we pick up the bishop and that should be
the solution
something better I don't see any other
candidate move move one queen g4 what
else would it be and you know King f8 I
don't know what other follow-up there
would be besides throwing a punch at the
knight on c4
that on I really don't see anything more
clean G for Queen C for ya oh I didn't
see that counter-attacking move okay
yeah I probably should have seen them
striking at the night staying on the
same color square yeah there is a night
to be six now I know what to do from
here but I should have at least
seeing that this was a possibility
well no I'm mistaken maybe I don't know
what to do here yes I do okay
the knight is defending the rook I was
thinking we come over here and then go
here to win the rook let the rook is
defended actually the Queen on h8 would
be mate so we play to h4 we're now
threatening the bishop and a mate in one
okay
wasn't a super-clean approach to solving
this one but okay I think I had the
right idea at least to go after that
unprotected night
I'm a little bit curious about something
before I go into the third and final one
and that is on this check on g4 suppose
the king went here instead okay
Oh
J we still come over to c4 in uh Knight
b6 we go to h4 once more
and I hit to its check-in then we pick
up the bishop at the very least okay
let's try one last one team light whoa
feels like an opening disaster in a way
for both sides what happened to the
Kings okay uh where's the night
okay Bishop Knight and queen are going
to have to work some magic
Bishop will not be helping out white can
afford a waiting move there is no great
punch that black and throw it white
if it is black on move and not even a
single check
so let's see Bishop check Queen check
knight check I'm going to roll that one
out for the moment Queen is covering
that
so on a bishop check in King here that
will run into main two with Queen e8
queen us to block we pick up the Queen
so Bishop check King takes night
what are we doing there
okay I mean we could go with the Queen
shot
as well that's that's most forceful yeah
that's most forceful okay that's
probably it then it doesn't even allow
King takes tonight and I could lean on
what I just said about waiting move or a
quiet move I should say we can't afford
a quiet move after Queenie six the King
has to go back home and then I think
that's the moment where we make a quiet
move 95 seems pretty strong this would
there be something more forceful after
Queenie six king home I don't see any
good check
oh wait a second after Queenie six King
here I was just thinking if I could some
ago somehow get my Bishop to f7 put the
Queen's in in a way what about Queen f5
solution is Queen f5 clean f5 if the
pond blocks is just
point this out real quick I've done upon
block we take the pawn for me
in a 5k
back home Bishop f7 is made
two more to go King takes night
d6 well on Queen f5 King d6 we have a
main one
and on Queen f5 King takes night we have
a matin - forcing the King to the d6
square first Queen b5 King D 6 and then
Queen on d5 and there's no retreat
squares for the king that's mate
so Meghan one two three I guess in the
end for this one
let's put it on
clean d5 and now d5 for mate
well I think that was a decent group of
three feel free to share how you did
with these three we'd like in the
comments section below
and as usual I hope you got something
out of this
hope you're having a great day and I
will catch you soon take care
you
[Music]